it's Correa de Sanabria
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up guys how's it going
all right here we go this is worth it
season two finale are you ready we did
it an episode very similar to this in a
town Los Angeles now we're in cake
country we're here in Korea because we
had an opportunity to eat Korean style
ribs with world-renowned chef David
Chang and of course we had to bring
along throwback to season one Evon gong
whoa what is that
the Korean Hearts Adam join us in this
love square today my friend we're gonna
be trying three different IB spots at
three drastically different price points
to find out which one is the most worth
it at its price what is that you ask
having is Korean short ribs soft else
it's like hi baby it's not galbi but
it's like cattle be no he's out Korean
ending you okay I'm not Korean Korean on
the show so we are here at and how do
you say this place Connie I'm Chi McGee
let's say say how I might pronounce it
as a Korean person which is like
perfectly bad yeah
Gangnam caught Gangnam got McGee Gangnam
del maguey perfect so we probably talked
about who you are I'm David Chang and I
founded Momofuku in New York and we have
restaurants all over the place right now
I mean you're here in Korea when was the
last time you came here I was here seven
years ago and I tend to not come to
create too much because I had a strange
relationship growing up as a Korean
American I lived in Northern Virginia so
it was basically white people during the
week and like only Asians on the weekend
and then as they grew up it was like I
was in-between but the one food that I
felt that could connect a non-korean
audience to a Korean food is Korean
barbecue what's cool about coming to
Korea you have restaurants that like
specialize in one thing and supposedly
this restaurant specializes in the short
rib finger so basically when you eat a
rib the meat that's right off the bone
if you cut it a certain way you can
actually just get that in its entirety
all right now my body's ready oh cool
they cooked it with charcoal other ones
you're gonna turn on the gas
I love the fact that Koreans just use
scissors as the tool for everything
including these are things to me that
are like very representative Korean
culture we're gonna do it our way
because it
we don't give up or two things real
pleasure here we get our food yeah it's
for a friend [ __ ] can you edit the sound
Chang's grilling our meats is the real
the real trick of this show here's the
thing you think I'm gonna let you guys
maybe it's not like I want to but it's
like the lesser of two evils you're off
and you with what's the role here how do
you know when finish that's like a
certain one you know to kiss a girl I
don't I think the entire audience know
that check out a few little heavy taco
and they'd Tom come to me comedy isn't
about flavor obviously it is but it's
about your ability to customize however
the hell you want to eat on its own it's
just simply it's gonna be delicious
that's why it's so great for group
outings Evan wouldn't you agree for
someone that's ordering in a Korean
restaurant that they need to find the
courage to be as rude as possible like
if they're the meek like excuse me
yeah no they're not gonna see you what
do you do when you go to a restaurant
that doesn't have a call button and you
have to get the waiters attention yogi
are you guys laughs good luck ordering
food next time was the call button
invented to just get be able to stop
yelling baby haha I think you should try
to eat that chili pepper is it good yeah
oh that's spicy
ah why did I eat that you don't want to
hear I would say the Chili Peppers for
the end why so I can taste the food
get some water it's not that bad do this
get that go joy my face I'm gonna
FaceTime you later when I'm on the
toilet you can see how much it really
hurts about your know that was that I
mean I'm fine let's go you're a pretty
good chef right like you're okay you
know I've seen some videos you love you
online and I'm just like that's that
nobody's doing like I could do that you
like your viewers must feel about your
ability all right
I can't tell if it was because you were
cooking it or the meat was good that it
was a good experience was it both could
be yours curry effect
yeah Korea fact criticized as of 2016
the average internet connection speed in
Korea was the Internet is faster in
Korea that's all you hear about you hook
up the Wi-Fi you're like wow that's
faster that's the only fact you got we
do one fact for car ride what do you
want more fat yeah you know you're
really breaking the structure here do
you guys know anything about the turtle
ship uh-oh create a fax it is considered
one of the great military feats of Korea
wouldn't you say oh I agree
it was unlike the 17th century Korea has
been dominated by the Mongols by the
Japanese so they created this ship that
basically is called a turtle ship
because it was impenetrable and it
spikes on so it couldn't be boarded
nothing really happened other than they
couldn't beat the ship that to me is
sort of the definition of like Korean
culture we may lose the battle but we
have this guy named turtle [ __ ] all
right so we gotta move on here we're
going to a nice little place called
video translate it into Cal field
place here
[Music]
hi my name is injunction I'm an owner of
this restaurant called Saudi riyal is
Korean traditional Kotb restaurant our
specialty is beef Calvi
we marinate for 82 hours 82 hours so it
takes more than three days to prepare
the Chi B for us yes we boil lots of
fruits and vegetables in soy sauce for
10 hours who get foot extract we
marinate for 24 hours for that shows
into beef and the marinated for 48 hours
you are going to have side dishes so
function water-based kimchi and japchae
is a Korean traditional fried noodle
some Korean vegetables and spicy root
crops that's a side dish yeah it comes
for free crab for free Wow Steven loves
crab and lobster and oysters and yeah a
little see you guys alright so we are
now here at em you gotta help me out
with the pronunciation or doing your
code iyanya translation
Calvillo do you own a Cal field no okay
so how's the stomach say it I'm ready
for round two
how's the know we had this very special
drink here so it's like two times wrong
under soldiers are you enjoying this
I've been sure this is my last drink
smells like sake Cheers
I'm scared mmm I can't finish that Oh
vital ad in the transfer to any
situation
[Music]
is this raw yeah yeah baby cheers guys
cares oh that sounds that is awesome :
that's right that's fresh usually it's
in soy sauce I've never seen anything
like a quarter dollar scoffing I know
this is about puppy but in my humble
opinion that crabs the best thing I've
had to eat in Korea I really want to
take a photo just so remember when we
got here this is a marinated short rib
in their special sauce right harsher
wheat in some John and Tom so it goes
well with finish this garlic sauce this
is insanely delicious Wow this is almost
like the filet mignon of the short rib
right it's the fancy part of the cow of
the bad part of a cat correct Adam
hey where's the love for the sound guy
man and it sounds like I'm over here
there we go baby this is a very Korean
thing perilla leaf is the English name
but this is called get you it's two very
distinct in its flavor I'm gonna just do
it one of these guys this meat is
incredible hmm wrap it up in this is so
good I've never had anything like that
it's almost like a really wild intense
mint or basil right the first place we
went to is like the heavy drinking spot
like it's gonna get better the more you
have to drink how did you characterize
this place I think and it's really
cheesy to say what separates this food
versus anything else is when you eat
something this delicious you can just
tell that they care a little bit more a
littl little of love yes I find myself
taking every bite a little bit more
carefully here
guys I got a tap out there I'm not come
round sound no I forgive you for all the
meanings you said this is what I
actually want I'm excited to be here for
you guys but this is extraordinarily
delicious you got to tell me how you
make the kid Johnny it's made with fresh
raw crap to make that those with fried
with gochujang and vegetables and foots
and some other resources there's
something about sucking on the shell and
just like using your jaw to gusher it
into your tongue that is beautiful
description
going to town on that crab one of the
best things you've ever had to eat right
this gives me so much joy looking at a
guy like you know no judging but
definitely judging I did never thought
that you're like you're like yeah this
is gonna be one of the best things I've
already why is you want to cut that up
I'm okay I want to cut mine up wait yogi
oh yeah why is this a classic pairing
with the meal we just this is a peasant
as you can get right when you have beef
you try to extract that as long as
possible so you make a soup out of it
all the scrap hmm is it okay for me to
say that's my favorite thing today yeah
the most like simple you can have fun
yeah you know what I'm kind of sad that
you're living on thank you thanks guys
for having me
yeah that's delicious me and Davey poo I
thought that went great I think you
should try to eat the chili pepper hmm
Andrew what to think that was the best
Korean barbecue I've ever had oh wow
Korea fast whoa yeah yeah I love it
how do you say Korea fact in Korean
Hangul Peck to Waverly yeah I'm saying
McDonald's delivers in Korea it's called
MEC delivery I would never have guessed
what does it call when you have Korean
barbecue delivery barbecue but kebab
prick delivery deliver cue oh my body is
not ready to put the last spot but we
must forge ahead we're going to a hotel
try a cow that is specifically bred in
Korea you know go to Coachella
[Music]
[Applause]
laissez openin young-soon Amida German
Walker hotel and Regina always yeonggi
nobody named spirit is a cigar related
acquaintance aerobic with Smita Choi dal
Ghanaian Superga it will be so mean W
yeah signals from a neutral zone enjoy
gap in again
hello Tim hello Tim gotta be to
configure the currently that were having
today what makes that so delicious so
special yunnan china is a cutie
congenially true pony does indeed
hydrology hang geometry continually at
all hi okay so who m3 China and the
Bible original King James was she
watching recession in their careers off
to forgiving her to Smith confirmed I'll
be the source I'm available yeah he
appear something creams in Google Katya
what about it has a laundry room man
check out okay man degrees Mira Terran
is Coco gave you saw so you guys are
gonna handle it who's won but who are
you man
so bogeys at Guillemot having a common
message on the History Center cubic
Martin welcome technically or said and
Andromeda will be repelled Cheers
it is so refreshing to drink wine after
a whole day of beer and soju
so the kimchi here they actually make
in-house or should I say in hotel haha
they have a room that's like five times
as big as this that just ferments kimchi
and then they package it fresh look at
that it's beautiful yeah kimchi cheers
Tim cheers Cheers
kimchi
a lot more vinegary than earlier
kimchi's of the day mmm it's powerful
who would have punched my mouth flavor
that's a three-peat do you just lay down
there it's kind of like a flag
if this bone just extended down you
could just like a wave this flag of meat
around look at the marbling on this Wow
look at that that looks pretty magical I
love that we're eating a $300 piece of
meat that's being cut up with scissors
bruising wait very fun oh look at that
collect right there or the booth
perishing good Cheers
[Music]
holy crap oh my god I didn't need to get
better than the last buck tell me what
you're tasting character is like I beat
that we've had today has been like kind
of chewy weird this one just like melts
it's totally is melt in your mouth you
could see the veins of fat running
through that the Han River flowing
through every bite I take more juices
just explode in my mouth why don't I pop
a morsel into a man's mouth right now
Evan the weirdest thing ever
how is that all right get out of here
it's a celebration meat this is like
just got the greatest promotion of my
life hot of that baby born
hundred time are you having a baby soon
no no not Stevens pregnant with a food
baby
wanting my good thing what's your
favorite thing hanging out with the
north head boys was your fingers the
changes chairs Adam cheer for you let's
go home can we weekend that was an
incredible experience I mean the juice
got loose from that meat isn't that
diamond cutting which IV was the most
worth it and it's given last one so at
Gotham gaol Meggie I do really like that
it's a hangout spot but my worth it
winner has to be cow field because even
if you eliminate all the other factors
their meat was the most delicious meat
we ate today no question ever I think
I'm gonna say my favorite restaurant was
the third place Wow all I can say he's
the hommies making my country proud I'm
so glad I got to try a hundred but I'm
gonna say my favorite was healthier at
that play it's like you sit back you
relax I mean bring the munch here now
see also those rooms or you could sit on
the floor I don't want to do that what
do you think Adam who's your that winner
they can't see your face
that's it for season two thank you to
everybody who has watched sweet we'll be
coming at you fresh with a season three
with the worth it boys
Adam do it see the season three baby
have you read the comments yeah dawg
they're mostly about how Adam is a
precious cinnamon roll too perfect for
this world that's an internet thing